AND I THANK YOU KINDLY.
HERE IS THE PUCK BACK A CHANCE .
TUCH TRYING TO HELP HIM OUT.
CAME TO THE BLUE LINE. WAS TAKEF
THE THINGS RIGHT HERE THEY GET
IN THAT AREA, THEY WANT TO LET
AND WENT WAY BACK IN HIS OWN
END.
NOWOPPORTUNITY.
SEBASTIAN AHO COMING UP THROUGH
HERE, HITS THE BLUE LINE, RIGHT
AND TAPPED BACK AROUND THE
BUFFALO NET BUT KEPT IN THERE.
RIGHT IN FRONT O TO THE OTHER
END OF THE COYNEIN IN A HURRY.
>> Refer
CASEY MITTELSTADT LETH
SOROKIN AND BEATS HIM JUST
INSI
OKPOSO HITS THE ISLANDEROINT.
TOKARSKI STILL CAUGHT ON TOP OF
THE CREASE AND IT KEIM OFF THE .
FIRED THE
MIDDLE OF THE
SCREEN, LOOK HOW LOW THE KILLERS
ARE FOR THE THIS ONE.
THIS WENT FAROES TO
CENTER AND THE ISLANDERS COMING
BAB THE OTHER DIRECTION.
THE SHOT OFF THE SIDE OF THE MS
>> Rob: NOW YOU'RE RETIRING,
R. THE FAR FOREHAND ANDFTER IT.
HE WENT TO THE NET AND SCORED. .
THIS IS A NICE GOAL.
GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR JUST TRICKL
OVER THE BLUE LINE -- OR THE RE.
JOKIHARJU, WHO HAD TWO OR THREE
WHACKS AT IT, NOT
LIKE THAT PUCK IS LIVE, HE
PULLS IT OVER T LET IT SLIDE